[Música]
esta música es en este momento en algún
lugar más allá del sistema solar
[Música]
la quinta sinfonía de beethoven está
grabada en el disco de oro que viaja
dentro de la sonda voyager el objetivo
de la voyager no es otro que darnos a
conocer ante cualquier forma de vida
extraterrestre que la encuentre
mientras tanto el 2 de marzo de 2019
spacex realizó el primer vuelo de prueba
de lo que en un futuro serán viajes
comerciales al espacio
si usted acaba de morir desde que el día
de la reina
nativas de harris y prácticas de amor
en las últimas décadas los seres humanos
hemos soñado con romper la última
frontera descubrir nuevos planetas
conocer otras formas de vida pero la
exploración espacial tiene otros
atractivos que no se suelen mencionar
[Música]
ah
exacto hablamos de dinero nuestro
sistema solar está lleno de recursos
naturales
todos esos asteroides que viajan por el
universo están llenos de oro platino y
toda clase de metales
incluso algunas lunas de saturno son
auténticas bolas gigantes de gas natural
pensabas que algún día se agotarían los
recursos naturales de la tierra pues
tranquilo porque ahí fuera hay miles de
yacimientos por explotar y si todo esto
supone una auténtica fortuna
la minería espacial es la industria del
futuro o tal vez del presente
[Música]
y qué tiene que ver luxemburgo con todo
esto pues atentos porque el vídeo de hoy
os va a dejar boquiabiertos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os imagináis que pudiéramos sacar uranio
de una mina en un asteroide o que
pudiéramos extraer gas natural en
saturno no me he vuelto loco lo cierto
es que la minería espacial es ya una
realidad
[Música]
una nave espacial japonesa hayabusa 2
llega al asteroide ryuku para extraer
minerales y no creáis que hablamos de
poco dinero para que os hagáis una idea
cerca de la tierra hay un asteroide que
se llama la vida tiene un diámetro de
poco más de tres campos de fútbol pero
recursos naturales por valor de atentos
27 cuatrillones de dólares es decir que
estamos hablando de un 27 seguido de 18
ceros
[Música]
y atentos porque no es el único en
saturno hay un satélite que se llama
titán y que está hecho literalmente de
gas metano es decir que es una bola
entera de gas licuado que podría
abastecer a todo el planeta tierra
durante siglos esto podría ser el fin de
la guerra del gas y el fin de toda esa
dependencia que tenemos de dictaduras
que tienen recursos naturales suena
fantástico verdad pero aquí viene la
gran pregunta imaginad que queremos
explotar una mina de oro en australia en
este caso tendremos que seguir la
legislación australiana verdad cada país
tiene su propia legislación
algunos más estricta otros menos
estricta pero está claro quien legisla
qué
[Música]
sin embargo qué pasa si explotamos una
mina en un satélite que está en la
órbita de saturno a quién pertenece eso
quién regula los derechos de propiedad
por ejemplo imaginad que tenemos una
empresa de minería y nos vamos al
asteroide da vida para extraer el hierro
que contiene pero a la vez que llegamos
nosotros llega otra empresa a disputar
nos la mina como resolvemos el problema
con qué ley en qué tribunal pues bien
hasta ahora nadie se había preocupado
por legislar la minería espacial pues
bien hay un país que sí que ha empezado
a hacer sus deberes sabéis de quién
estoy hablando exacto
hablamos de luxemburgo
luxemburgo es ese país situado entre
bélgica francia y alemania- que tiene
menos población que todo manhattan y que
tienen de especial en luxemburgo pues
una palabra dinero si recordáis en este
vídeo os contábamos que luxemburgo es
uno de los países más ricos del mundo
pues bien cuando tienes dinero lo
inviertes
es verdad que hablamos de un país con
poco más de medio millón de habitantes
pero sin embargo han invertido ya más de
220 millones de dólares en minería
espacial tienen el capital tienen las
empresas que les faltaba efectivamente
la legislación pues aquí la tenéis
[Música]
nuestro objetivo es crear un entorno
legislativo para la exploración y uso
comercial de los recursos de los
llamados cuerpos celestiales como
asteroides o incluso la luna el cien
sneijder ex primer ministro de
luxemburgo y actual ministro de economía
según varias empresas del sector para el
año 2025 ya será rentable extraer cosas
como agua hidrógeno y metales preciosos
pero la pregunta es cómo funciona la
minería espacial y cómo va a funcionar
esta legislación estamos hablando de
algo serio o solamente son rumores hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el oro marciano como os podéis imaginar
mandar una nave espacial a un asteroide
es caro muy caro
así que si mahoma no puede ir a la
montaña la montaña va a mahoma
literalmente
hablamos de mover asteroides fuera de su
camino habitual y ponerles en la órbita
de nuestro planeta y diréis es esto
posible pues la respuesta es que si
según un estudio del instituto que
asteroides va a ser una realidad muy
pronto y pensad que este estudio se
publicó en el año 2012 siete años antes
de que hagamos este vídeo durante ese
tiempo las investigaciones han avanzado
una auténtica barbaridad y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando fonseca perú que te
has fumado pues anda que no tenemos nada
mejor que hacer que ponernos aquí a
construir una grúa de proporciones nacho
vidal ya nas para enganchar asteroides a
ver tranquilos el proceso es bastante
más sencillo veréis basta con que un
asteroide se acerque lo suficiente a un
cuerpo más grande como pueda ser la luna
o nuestro propio planeta como para que
la masa de la tierra lo arrastre hacia
su órbita así que lo único que tenemos
que hacer es empujar un poquito el
asteroide para que se desvíe de su rumbo
y se acerque a nuestra órbita todo esto
podría hacerse con una especie de misil
teledirigido sin embargo todo esto es la
teoría y ahora os preguntaréis pero hay
alguien que ya se haya puesto a
carl piedra en un asteroide pues la
respuesta es sí
la agencia espacial japonesa amando una
nave la hayabusa a un asteroide que se
llama 25 143 itokawa así que la primera
muestra de minerales espaciales llegó a
la tierra en el año 2010 poco después en
2016 la nasa mandó otra nave la llamada
osiris-rex al asteroide ven no en este
caso las muestras llegarán el año 2023 y
en este caso ya se pondrán en práctica
muchas de las tecnologías de minería
espacial sin embargo no todo es tan
sencillo
muchos de estos satélites giran en torno
a sí mismo a una velocidad tan rápida
que es prácticamente imposible poderlos
manejar eso significa que en muchos
casos habría que rodear a estos cuerpos
con cables que limitarán su movimiento y
como os podéis imaginar eso es
extremadamente caro
pero esperad un momento porque todo esto
son los problemas técnicos pero esto es
visual política aquí no vamos a competir
ni concede ciencia ni con cuanto un
fracture que hacen un trabajo fantástico
en su campo aquí vamos a hablar de
política y economía y creedme en este
sentido la minería espacial plantea un
montón de problemas ahora mismo los
vamos a ver
[Música]
luxemburgo imperio galáctico en el año
1967 se aprobó el primer tratado
internacional sobre el espacio exterior
eran los años de la guerra fría ya nadie
le importaba eso de la minería espacial
el auténtico terror de la época era que
eeuu o la unión soviética usaran los
satélites para aniquilar se el uno al
otro y eso es en lo que se centra este
tratado pero los tratados
internacionales son una cosa bastante
rara no hay ninguna policía mundial que
pueda obligar a los estados a cumplirlos
[Música]
todo lo que se puede hacer es imponer
sanciones comerciales así que en la
práctica la legislación internacionales
pues no sé cómo las reglas del parchís
cada uno las interpreta como quiere como
nota curiosa os diré y donald trump ya
está barajando la idea de crear un
ejército espacial
el otro día estaba pensando oye hacemos
un trabajo tremendo en el espacio a lo
mejor tendríamos que crear un ejército
espacial no lo decía en serio pero luego
me dije
pues es una buena idea igual lo tenemos
que hacer por extraño que suene esta no
es la primera vez que un presidente
estadounidense dice algo así en el año
ronald reagan propuso construir el
llamado proyecto de la guerra de las
galaxias la idea era poner una red de
satélites capaces de interceptar un
posible ataque de misiles soviéticos el
proyecto era tan caro que tuvieron que
cerrarlo pero desde luego a nadie parece
importarle un [ __ ] que ese proyecto
violar aplastantemente el tratado del
espacio exterior
y os preguntaréis pero qué dice la
legislación internacional sobre la
minería espacial pues básicamente dos
cosas la primera es que cualquier
organización no gubernamental lo cual
incluye a las empresas necesita un
permiso de un estado para poder
marcharse al espacio exterior la segunda
es que nadie puede restringir la
investigación científica pero qué pasa
con la explotación comercial
pues ahí no lo sabemos y por eso tanto
eeuu como luxemburgo han sacado sus
propias leyes para permitir que los
inversores se puedan lanzar a la carrera
espacial y atentos porque esto es muy
importante tanto luxemburgo como eeuu
tienen una cosa muy especial
veréis en casi todos los países del
mundo los recursos naturales se
consideran estratégicos es decir que si
tú vives en argentina por ejemplo y te
encuentras petróleo en tu jardín no
puedes explotarlo porque no es tuyo ese
petróleo es del gobierno y por tanto
ellos deciden cuándo cómo y quién
explota ese zumo de dinosaurio
sin embargo si vives en california o
luxemburgo y encuentras petróleo en tu
jardín estás de enhorabuena ese petróleo
es tuyo y lo explotas cuando como y con
quien quieras pero el caso de luxemburgo
es aún más especial que el del 'tío sam'
tienen una ventaja única veréis la ley
estadounidense dice que solo las
empresas nacionales pueden tener permiso
para explotar minas en el espacio y que
hace falta para que una empresa sea
estadounidense pues tiene que tener sus
oficinas dentro del país y los dueños
tienen que ser residentes oficiales en
eeuu sin embargo y aquí viene lo
interesante en el caso de luxemburgo
basta con tener una oficina fiscal en el
país
[Música]
es decir que te basta con hacer un
trámite burocrático tener un buzón en el
país para que te lleguen las cartas de
hacienda y santas pascuas tienes una
empresa en luxemburgo en otras palabras
imaginad que una empresa española
quisiera explotar los recursos de un
satélite que está por el espacio
exterior
basta con que hagan un viaje de ida y
vuelta al país de jean-claude juncker y
listo ya pueden irse a donde quieran por
si todo esto fuera poco luxemburgo tiene
muchos menos impuestos que eeuu en otras
palabras que con la ley estadounidense
sólo los estadounidenses se pueden
beneficiar de la minería espacial
[Música]
sin embargo luxemburgo acaba de abrir
todo un nuevo sector económico al mundo
entero y eso explica que tantísimos
inversores hayan elegido este país para
sus proyectos hablamos de un sector tan
grande que ya existe todo un clúster
empresarial dedicado a la minería del
espacio es decir una asociación
empresarial apoyada por el propio
gobierno para dar visibilidad a todos
estos proyectos
ah
para que os hagáis una idea hablamos de
30 empresas con 700 trabajadores y que
ya genera un volumen de negocio de 2 mil
millones de euros y como os podéis
imaginar hay muchísimas voces críticas
las naciones unidas entre otros
algunos economistas de izquierdas como
claro el cic man que es un discípulo de
thomas piketty han llegado a decir cosas
como esta luxemburgo está extendiendo la
lógica de ser un paraíso fiscal a una
nueva era y lo cierto es que todavía hay
un par de problemas legales que el
luxemburgo necesitará resolver recordáis
ese tratado espacial de 1967 pues bien
en el artículo 1 dice que los estados
estarán obligados a compartir los
beneficios de sus exploraciones con el
resto del mundo pero qué significa esto
pues nadie lo sabe a ciencia cierta
porque como os decía los tratados
internacionales son como las reglas del
parchís están bastante abiertos a las
interpretaciones
significa que si sacamos oro de un
asteroide lo tenemos que repartir a
partes iguales entre los más de 190
países del mundo y cómo lo hacemos quién
hace el reparto se lo damos a cada
gobierno
tal vez nos limitamos a pagar un
impuesto en ese caso quién cobraría el
impuesto el gobierno del mundo también
podríamos decir que traer recursos
naturales al planeta tierra es algo
necesario de lo que nos beneficiamos
todos indirectamente en otras palabras
que se trata de un párrafo abierto a
todo tipo de interpretaciones pero todo
esto no son más que futuribles así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que luxemburgo podrá terminar
creando su propio imperio espacial hasta
qué punto este país tan pequeño puede
cambiar la economía mundial
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo
y hasta pronto
[Música]